[Musica]
buonasera grazie non essendo molto
abituato questi i riflettori vorrei
iniziare con delle domande direttamente
per per voi potete rispondere
semplicemente alzando la mano quanti di
voi ordinano a pizza telefonando al
pizzaiolo di fiducia praticamente tutti
quanti di voi invece ordinano pranzo e
cena online
troppo pochi qualcun altro
quanti mangiano grilli 2 è la stessa
reazione che avevo anch'io quando in
asia mi offrivano degli alimenti per
particolari insomma dopo diversi anni in
asia sono tornato in italia per seguire
un idea che a che fare con il futuro
dell'alimentazione ovvero cibo sano
personalizzato consegnato a domicilio
ci sono tre importanti trend in questo
ovvero il cibo a domicilio il cibo
personalizzato e il cibo sano sono tutti
trend che nascono dal mondo digitale
però vorrei fare una buona premessa
quando parliamo di come il digitale
cambia le nostre abitudini oggi non
possiamo più pensare al digitale che
opera in un unico verso in quanto il
digitale oggi è parte fondante delle
nostre abitudini
immagino che tutti voi facciate
qualsiasi cosa con lo smartphone quindi
va inteso non più come unica di
direttiva ma come un circolo quindi
quando il digitale entra in gioco le
abitudini cambiano ma il digitale stesso
evolve e le abitudini cambieranno ancora
con tantissime correlazioni in
tantissimi ambiti
pensate a
dieci anni fa quando e se avevate same
lui non avevate nulla in frigo l'unica
soluzione che potevate avere era o
uscire e andare a cena oppure a chiamare
il pizzaiolo
oggi invece sul vostro smartphone avete
pressoché l'offerta totale della città
quindi se avete voglia di riso patate e
cozze di orecchiette e cime di rapa
qualunque cosa
pizza focaccia in mezz'ora sono a casa
vostra
questo ha un impatto sulle abitudini
molto più più profondo di quello che che
pensiamo si sta di più a casa e si va
molto meno al ristorante questo grafico
che vedete il il colore scuro è gente
che mangia online mentre il il colore
chiaro e gente che mangia al ristorante
quindi si stima che nel 2020 ci saranno
più persone che mangeranno a casa
ordinando online piuttosto che persone
che andranno al ristorante
cosa vuol dire questo in termini di
ristorazione vuol dire che i ristoranti
saranno sempre più piccoli quindi non
avranno più più bisogno degli spazi che
hanno oggi e in alcuni casi si arriverà
addirittura a non avere il ristorante
quindi è così dette d'archi censo
ristoranti digitali ovvero delle cucine
che non hanno il ristorante ma fanno
solo servizio a domicilio ancora si
cucina molto meno tra un'indagine fatta
negli stati uniti tra i millennials
ovvero tra i giovani tra i 20 ei 35 anni
è emerso che cucinano a casa
un'unica volta a settimana ovvero un
pasto su su 14 includendo tra questi
pasti anche prepararsi l'insalata ora o
riscaldare qualcosa al micron
questi trend sono fortemente intersecati
anche con uno dei dei problemi più
rilevanti che abbiamo è che avremo il
mondo che è quello del sovraffollamento
ci sono molti contesti in cui lo spazio
è veramente un lusso ad hong kong se
provate ad affittare una una stanza vi
danno 15 metri quadri per 1.500 euro a
tokyo
se dovete prendere un hotel state
attenti a non prenderli hotel a capsula
se non dormirete per una notte in una
capsula di plastica di due metri per uno
in tutti questi contesti dove lo spazio
è veramente scarse ed è quindi è una una
risorsa molto preziosa a cucina sarà ed
è anche parzialmente un un lusso quindi
man mano che la popolazione aumenterà
sempre più le cucine diventeranno sempre
più più rare e si andrà verso un
concetto di casa senza a cucina in
africa ad ora si pensa che ci sia il più
grosso boom demografico dei prossimi
anni alle città arriveranno a contenere
50 milioni di persone probabilmente le
case non avranno e cucine noi viviamo
oggi in un mondo che è particolarmente
digitalizzato è un mondo molto
digitalizzato in cui si può ottenere
tutto e subito il mondo di di amazon in
cui se uno vuole vuole qualcosa va
online in poche ore alla sua porta
cosa c'è ancora cosa sì si può fare
oltre il tutto il subito a risposta e
personalizzare la personalizzazione
viene concessa grazie appunto lo
sviluppo digitale in quanto grazie agli
algoritmi alle intelligenze artificiali
si può oggi elaborare un infinità di
dati in tempo reale cosa che prima non
era possibile dare un'esperienza
all'utente assolutamente diversa dall
esperienza di qualcun altro
è questo il più grosso di sviluppo che
ci sarà nel mondo dell'e commerce in
futuro nell'ambito nutrizionale cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che attraverso dei
dei test si può arrivare a
personalizzare un menu o a
personalizzare alcuni piatti proprio per
essere più coerenti con le colle
necessità attraverso un test
nutrizionale in cui il cliente compila
tutte le informazioni personali oi dati
o le preferenze eccetera eccetera si
possono consigliare alcuni piatti oppure
si può personalizzare appunto un menù
una una dieta ad hoc
c'è anche chi in america lo fa
analizzando il corredo genetico quindi
analizzando il dna mamma la
nutrigenetica diciamo è una una scienza
che sta ancora consolidandosi
insomma il cibo per personalizzato di di
per sé anche cibo sano per chiaramente
personalizziamo per dare il meglio
all'individuo dicevamo prima che c'è una
grandissima facilità di acquisto oggi di
cibo
questo è anche problematico perché
chiaramente la disponibilità di
qualunque tipo di cibo può avere degli
effetti negativi infatti nella prima
fase del dl fu delivery l'offerta era
era pressoché di massa quindi fast food
kebab pizza quant'altro patatine
eccetera eccetera questo avuto
chiaramente degli effetti negativi sulle
abitudini alimentari è un peggioramento
di quelli che erano già dei dei dati
abbastanza brutti ovvero quelli sul sui
sui tassi di obesità e sovrappeso
questo è stato particolarmente grave
nelli negli stati uniti dove addirittura
il il governo obama con l'università di
harvard sono intervenuti con una con una
campagna che la chiamata choose my plate
per sensibilizzare l'opinione pubblica
verso una sana e corretta alimentazione
riprendendo un po quelli che sono i temi
e i principi della dieta mediterranea e
del piatto unico bilanciato ovvero un
piatto composto da cereali verdure
proteine che per noi è abbastanza ovvio
ma non per tutti quindi
[Musica]
l'altro tema che che vedevamo prima e
quello del sovraffollamento
man mano che la popolazione aumenterà le
come dicevano tutti gli altri le risorse
diminuiranno pesce carne saranno sempre
più più rari anche a chi no a l'avvocato
che vanno tanto di moda ora saranno
sempre più rari e più costosi servono
delle alternative che possono essere
prodotte in laboratorio o che vengono da
contesti differenti quindi da abitudini
alimentari di mondi a noi hanno i
lontani come per esempio l'asia e qui si
inserisce il grande tema degli insetti
come cibo del del futuro è un cibo
sostenibile e profittevole nutriente e
sano
per questo possiamo dire che il futuro
sarà fatto da cibo sano personalizzato e
preferibilmente consegnato a domicilio
essere abbastanza ironico e strano tra
trent'anni ordinare degli degli insetti
online come se sia una una una cosa
ovvia
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]